and I got a football scholarship it
basically changed the course of my life
took me out of that one-bedroom
apartment in the hood put me on a
college campus and started my career as
a journalist so here we are it's the
Sunday special my special guest today is
Jason Whitlock he is the host of Fox
Sports ones
speak for yourself and we have a lot to
get to today obviously sports have been
in the news in a major way and Jason's a
really unique thinker we're gonna talk
to him for the full hour as Larry can we
put it but first I want to say thanks to
our sponsors over at zip recruiter so
hiring is challenging but there's one
place you can go our hiring is simple
and fast and smart it's a place where
growing businesses connect to qualified
candidates that place is zip recruiters
calm and use the slash bed and guess
because they get a special deal zip
recruiter sends your job to over 100 of
the web's leading job boards but they
don't stop there with their powerful
matching technology zip recruiter scans
thousands of resumes to find people with
the right experience and invite them to
apply to your job and as the
applications come in zip recruiter
analyzes each one they spotlight the top
candidates so you never miss a great
match the zip recruiter is so effective
80% of employers who post on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site within the first day
which should be of little comfort to the
people in this room me I can fire them
all tomorrow and just zip recruit I'll
make it that much better with results
like that it's no one or zip recruiter
is the highest rated hiring site in
America and right now my listeners can
try zip recruiter for free at this
exclusive web addresses if recruiter
comm slash been guest because I have a
guest at zipper career.com been guest
ven gue est zip recruiters comm slash
been guest it is the smartest way to
hire and as I say you're gonna want to
try because it makes sure that you got
the best candidates it also ensures that
you are the person who has the most
control over those candidates you'll
make your company better check it out
zip recruiters comm slash been guests to
let them know we sent you and a try it
out for free
alrighty so Jason Whitlock thanks so
much for coming in I really appreciate
it honored to be here really
appreciative see you so Jason for folks
who don't know and who are listening
Jason I'm just gonna get this right out
you're black so if you're listening and
you couldn't tell Jason is a black man
and that means that because he does not
subscribe to the sort of leftist party
platform on a bunch of issues that we're
going to be talking about Jason is the
preeminent sports journalism Uncle Tom
is that is that the language they
typically
would be accurate over Twitter and
social media I don't know if my mom and
family would agree with that so let's
get into it let's start there let's
start with you know what your upbringing
is and then we'll get into politics and
sports cuz obviously that intersection
is becoming incredibly incredibly
popular and powerful right now so where
do you come up what's your background
I'm from Indianapolis Indiana of my
parents my dad was a high school dropout
joining the army came back and became a
entrepreneur in the inner city my mom
high school graduate factory worker they
divorced when I was young four or five
years old I have an older brother and so
me and my brother move we live with my
mom
initially start out in the hood
my mom our apartment gets broken into
when me and my brother on a weekend trip
visiting with my dad and his new wife
and my mom didn't tell us at the time
but she was at home when someone broke
into our apartment climbed through the
window and she just happened to wake up
and walk in the kitchen the guys in the
in the window
she takes a second job and moves us to a
working-class neighborhood and that kind
of started changing the direction of our
life my senior year of high school
though my mom had because of her job
transfer to Kansas City Missouri I move
in with my dad and at this time my dad
is flat on his butt me and my dad lived
in a one hundred square foot one-bedroom
apartment my senior year of high school
I stayed in that because I was an
excellent high school football player
and I got a football scholarship that
basically changed the course of my life
took me out of that one-bedroom
apartment in the hood put me on a
college campus and started my career as
a journalist so how did that work which
college did you go to and how did you
actually get into the sports journalism
side of things as opposed to just
playing
Ball State University was where I got
the football scholarship about an hour
north of Indianapolis the journalism
thing came because when I was a kid my
dad's a huge newspaper reader and huge
Pacer fan I
was a huge pacer fan and so I started
following the Pacers in the newspaper
everyday and one day I ran across a
column from Mike Royko outside of the
sports section and I instantly fell in
love with microwork oh and so that
started my passion for newspaper Beyond
was just the sports section and so when
I get to college originally I'm signed
up to be an accounting major I get into
math class and say my counties not for
me and a friend said Jason you read the
newspaper every day you should be a
journalist and my mind immediately went
oh man I want to be like Mike and not
Jordan but I want to be like Mike Royko
and ever since then that was my passion
I switched my major to journalism and I
wanted to be the micro eco sport that's
amazing so how did you get your first
job where did you go from there
interesting B I played football at Ball
State and I socialized at Ball State and
I occasionally studied to be the next
microwave cook so I wasn't really
qualified for a full-time job when I
graduated from Ball State I played
football I hadn't done internships like
kids did during my era and so I got a
part-time job in Bloomington Indiana at
$5 an hour covering high school sports
in Bloomington Indiana where Indiana
University is and I tell young people
this one of the reasons I was able to
take that job at five dollars an hour is
because I had no responsibilities I
didn't have a kid I wasn't married
there was no responsibility I had so I
could start at the very bottom for very
little money I lived in a one-room
efficiency and I just worked really
really hard from there to move up and I
ended up from I did that for a year then
I got a job at the Charlotte Observer
covering high school sports and I think
I got that job for four hundred and
three dollars a week again not a lot of
money but I was passionate did that for
about 18 months and then I got a job at
the Ann Arbor News and Ann Arbor
Michigan covering the Fab five
basketball team and that pretty much
launched my career covered Michigan
football and basketball for those two
years and then got a column writing job
in 1994 at the Kansas City Star and
that's when I got to start trying to be
the microwaveable sport and that's
that's where I first saw you so I first
engaged with your material because I
used to get up really early in the
morning with my dad on Sunday mornings
and we hop in the den and before my
sisters were awake and we turn on sports
reporters on ESPN and you were a
frequent guest on our works recorders
when one of my favorite guests on sports
reporters and there it was that I first
saw that you had a different political
perspective and a different worldview so
let's talk a little bit about what
shaped your worldview because before we
get to what your worldview is and and
all the ways in which this distinguishes
you and why you taking so much flak for
that worldview what do you think your
biggest influences were in terms of
world you because you're not really an
overtly political guy per se no my
biggest influences are my grandmother
mama lovey was my mom's mom she's the
greatest human being that's ever existed
she put a religious foundation in me my
brother my mother by everybody and so I
grew up in a little small Church in
Indianapolis that my mother took us to
every Sunday it was my grandmother's
Church and so that's probably the most
critical piece of of what was put in me
and then I would say the second piece is
just my parents in terms of my dad again
he didn't graduate high school but he
joined the army after he got in a little
bit of trouble and then when he came
back that's when he got married to my
mom and all that but my dad became an
entrepreneur because he worked at the
Chrysler Motor Company Foundation and
he's reading the autobiography of
malcolm x on his lunch break and his
supervisor and a couple of co-workers
ridiculed and/or complained about him
reading the autobiography of malcolm x
and my dad ain't gonna work no where
were they telling me what I can read who
blah blah and so he started a barber
shop and then eventually he started a
small nightclub of black chairs in the
ghetto because he said I don't want to
work for people I want to be my own boss
and my dad worked at his bar eventually
he owned another one called the
masterpiece lounge and he worked at that
until his death
he built a brand new home in the black
community he carved out happiness for
himself here in America through his own
entrepreneurial spirit and what fit his
lifestyle he lived in the black
community he had a business in the black
community his existence was black and
relatively happy here in America my
mother again factory worker took a
second job to put me and my brother in a
safer environment went to work every day
one of the most amazing work ethics
you'll ever see in any human being but
particularly a woman at that time and so
me and my brother we just value going to
work every day and showing up and being
reliable because that's what our parents
were and so those two things and then
journalistically just becoming a micro
fan where I read his books and things
like that that kind of shaped my
worldview microwave Co was not someone
that I agreed with maybe 50% of the time
I agreed with his point of view but I
always thought he was coming from a very
honest real perspective that fit his
upbringing and I just enjoyed it and so
as when I moved into journalism I just
kept thinking about micro eco and it's
not whether I agree or disagree with you
are you coming from a real place is what
I value the most are you being authentic
to your upbringing and so I just think
those three things are probably because
right now to this day I can't tell you
what my coracle was politically I don't
know I truly don't know a Democrat I
know he was very critical of Mayor Daley
and the political machine there in
Chicago but I don't I don't know who he
voted for and maybe I'm an idiot but I I
read a lot of his columns I owned a lot
of his books but I don't know and so for
me I think we're we're probably go
negative I'm kind of a political I don't
like politics I've never voted troubles
my parents troubles everybody that knows
me but I just can't stand politics and
I'm skeptical of politicians their
authenticity but also
just as a journalist I recognized early
on I don't want anybody to judge me
based on my politics and so I stay out
of it for the most part and so that's
why I've I've never voted but and I also
think that if you're listening if you
tie in all the pieces together I just
have a working-class point of view I
think there's a lot of people that get
involved in the media and think and try
to pretend like they're representing the
point of view of the under of the
underclass or the lower-class or the
working class and they're really just
representing the views of the elite III
don't so many and this particularly I
think is a tube with black journalists
so many of them actually come from the
upper-class
that they don't really know how to
represent people from the lower class or
from the ghetto
or the disadvantaged they don't know how
and so what they're really representing
or elitist views and what works for
black people of privilege and my values
all come from a very work that my
father's bar was just working-class
people obviously my parents
working-class people my grandmother you
know worked at RCA just a working-class
person so that's what shaped my views
and then I think the personal
responsibility seems to be the one kind
of uniting moral value that you tend to
espouse and that brings into conflict
with a lot of the politics that have
been infused in sports I want to jump
into that a little bit which is let me
stop because I left off a big one I've
got a very big one football has shaped
my values and if you in sports have
shaped my values and if you understand
anything that's preached in sports in
any team environment and of it the if
there's a problem on the team don't look
outside the locker room every coach
preaches this we must fix our problems
right here within this locker room don't
blame the refs don't blame fans for not
showing up don't blame the other
teammates sheeted or whatever no no no
no right here we're going
fix our problems right and I just
believe in that so in the last couple of
years that perspective has come back to
both make you more prominent and also
bite you in the sense that colin
kaepernick obviously made big headlines
with his kneeling on the sidelines
routine and during the during the
national anthem and this obviously
become a cause celeb now for a lot of
folks on the political left and
obviously president Trump likes to talk
about it a lot and it's become this very
divisive issue you took the perspective
that Kaepernick shouldn't be doing that
and why do you think that is it seems
like there are a few different aspects
that there was the police brutality
aspect there was the national anthem
aspect where was that coming from well
okay I'll just and I don't want to
denigrate Colin Kaepernick but he didn't
come from where I came from and he was
adopted by a white suburban family he is
of mixed race I'm not denigrating any of
that I just it just fits in to my point
of view that he comes from a privileged
background whether he acknowledges it or
not and his worldview is privileged and
he thinks he's helping disadvantaged
and/or poor black people with what he's
doing and he's actually not they created
a calm he created a conversation about
the national anthem because nothing he
did was strategic again he thinks you
can affect change with emotion or with
some symbolic act that's not well
thought out he doesn't understand that
Martin Luther King and the people the
civil rights movement that was a very
strategic executed plan we're gonna
there was Rosa Parks wasn't the first
person who'd not give up her seat on the
bus another woman who had a legitimate
child did it first but they understood
that didn't work well politically so
let's have Rosa do it and that will
start the bus striking but so I just
think Kaepernick has done something
that's unplanned he started a
conversation about the national anthem
not about the issues he's saying he's
trying to address and I think it's
because he just doesn't know what he
doesn't know and I see social media
feeding his
lack of knowledge and anybody that tries
to step in and say hey Colin you're
making a mistake here
Colin there is a better way if you want
to address these issues there's a better
way anybody that does that get shouted
down as an awful Tom or a or
someone who doesn't have the interest of
black people when actually we're just
trying to say hey Kaepernick what you've
done isn't effective there's a better
way and perhaps because anybody that
knows Colin Kaepernick he's not equipped
to carry this conversation that's why he
avoids interviews he doesn't want to be
cross-examined because he'll fall apart
because he doesn't understand these
issues and so anybody like me who raises
a hand and says well hold on Colin and
your supporters I've actually had a very
close relative killed by police
brutality May 2012 Antoine Anton Butler
cousin that I helped raise I pay for his
funeral I shed real tears killed in
Indianapolis I understand how this
happens and it's not really about police
brutality because they don't understand
that there's an America is a
capitalistic society there's no money to
be made through police brutality that
costs the government money lots of money
there's always a settlement with the
family millions of dollars the
government is already very motivated to
stop police brutality because it's not
cost-effective mass incarceration is
actually a money-making industry and so
what I've tried to explain the black was
like let's say you want to go
conspiratorial what the government our
business interests actually have is
interest in people being politely
escorted to prison so they can make
money
you know they got beds to fill
themselves and the private critics they
need they don't need dead people there's
no money to be made that's a money loser
and so your argument falls apart and so
if you really understand what makes poor
people or anybody vulnerable to the
police it's the mass incarceration issue
but it's all
so just a society with as many guns as
we have I'm just this is this is going
to happen so I want to talk to you about
that in just one second because there's
a bunch of issues to unpack first I want
to say thanks to our sponsors over a
policy genius so look you know you need
life insurance but you just haven't
gotten around to it but guys haven't get
around what your are gonna be dead and
then you're screwed because you don't
have life insurance
so if anything were to happen it's
important that your loved ones are taken
care of and that's why policy genius
exists they've made comparing and buying
life insurance really easy they took the
whole shopping process online in five
minutes you can compare quotes from over
15 life insurance providers and when you
compare quotes you save money it's that
simple policy genius has helped over 4
million people shop for insurance
they've placed over 20 billion dollars
in coverage and they don't just insure
life they do everything else they can
compare health insurance and disability
insurance and pet insurance and renter's
insurance if you've been putting off
getting life insurance there's no reason
to put it off any longer I know you're
gonna go out on the lake this summer
and you might get killed the boating act
I'm not saying that's gonna happen to
you but if it were to do that if you
were to die in a boating accident make
sure that your family's at least taken
care of you idiot to go to policy genius
calm get quotes applying minutes it is
that easy
and you can do it right now and you
should because their rates are their
lowest in 20 years its policy genius
calm
it is indeed the easy way to compare it
and buy life insurance go over to policy
genius comm check it out
I promise it's really simple and it's
really easy and you're gonna be able to
use it you're gonna be able to get the
best rate again there is no excuse for
you not to do this right as a father of
two I promise you that I've got life
insurance for my kids my wife has life
insurance as well you should do exactly
the same thing so go over to policy
genius calm and again the search doesn't
take a lot of time it doesn't take a lot
of effort so check it out policy genius
calm again the easy way to compare and
buy life insurance ok so let's talk
about various factors that are playing
into and some of the stuff that
Kaepernick is protesting about the
supposed police brutality or
disproportionate shootings of black
people by the police you know I've
spoken about this many times the
statistics just do not support the idea
that black folks are being
disproportionately shot by the police in
fact Rowland fighters did a study from
Harvard University he found that in fact
black people were being statistically
under shot by the police if that's if
that's the case so in the in the kind of
pantheon of issues that are being
experienced by the black community in
terms of internal violence and conflicts
with the police
my suggestion has always been that if
you are going to solve the
issues you have to come at it from the
perspective of what you as an individual
can do and from where I sit it looks to
me like in any community black white or
green single motherhood and criminal
decisions are going to be your leading
causes of getting in trouble with the
police and one usually leads to the
other you know single motherhood is
disproportionately associated with with
high rates of crime high rates of
poverty and people who are not making
criminal decisions tend to have very far
less of a chance to have a run-in with
the police and then I want to talk about
your perspective on gun so first I want
to get your thoughts on that I think you
could just stop it single motherhood I
don't think you need to go any further
than that because what I explain to
people all this the first policeman that
a child should deal with and is supposed
to deal with or his two parents they're
supposed to police their children and so
if you find yourself in a culture where
there aren't two policemen called mom
and dad and your children are running
out unsupervised into America and now
you're under all these policemen who
didn't sign up to be their parents
aren't treating them the way we want
them to be treated well the first abuse
is this is the lack of parenting that's
the issue and so we have a culture as
African Americans where single
motherhood is prevalent it's 75% of our
kids and a repercussion of that is going
to be our kids are unsupervised and
we're asking other people who want their
parents to supervise them don't be
shocked when there's abuse and so when I
watched the riots in Baltimore and in
Ferguson all I kept thinking about look
at all these young people who has time
or to one be on the streets like this
but I was where the parents and and
again I I'm so upset with the media
because it's such an obvious issue that
has to be addressed and if we want as
black people to move forward and if we
want our society to look for
with black people we have to address
this issue
you destruction of the family is causing
much of this chaos and then to your
point this narrative that the police are
just out here indiscriminately killing
black men
it's just bogus and BS Ben it doesn't
factually hold up to statistics there
there are plenty of examples of the
police wrongly killing white people that
the media never addresses it never
touches because they what it seems to me
they want us racially divided and at
each other's throats it drives ratings
it drives emotion and you know people
tune in to watch and but it's just not
even remotely true I've seen the videos
of other races and so police sometimes
act inappropriately and they're you know
I'm not making any excuses for them but
again when you're in a society as
heavily armed as ours and so many
messages are sent to you about how
dangerous it is in these poor
communities or whatever it's going to
lead to mistakes happening and we can't
then demonize all police because some of
made mistakes some do have evil hearts
and act inappropriately but we can't
demonize them all it's just it's just
wrong and there's a book by Jane levy
over to the LA Times for a book called
ghetto side and her suggestion was that
one of the biggest problems that the
black community is having in terms of
elevated rates of crime is that
historically there's been under policing
in the black community that the white
community said to the black men you take
care of yourselves right we're not gonna
put our cops in there and put them in
danger you guys take care of yourselves
and so what that led to was gangs who
are gonna protect their members and who
are gonna fight other members and what
we really need at this point is more of
a police presence what you need is a
lowering of the crime rate and then
there just won't be as many run-ins with
the police because virtually every
ethnic group in the United States at one
point or another has had high crime
rates in the United States and they've
had elevated run-ins with the police as
a result the Italian community in the
United States in the early 20th century
is a great example of this where they
had elevated crime rates to the point
where
there were protests about why Italian
people were constantly being portrayed
as criminals on television and all this
and then the crime rates went down same
thing is true the Irish and the Germans
it's true early on of the Jews even and
then the crime rates went down and then
the run-ins with the police stopped so
the real question I guess is why do you
think it is that people who are
prominent in culture and in the black
community have not taken more of a
perspective just saying okay well let's
let's get our own house in order and
then we can talk about you know the
supposedly brutal problem that that's
happening I'm not saying they can't be
tackled simultaneously but it seems like
the amount of focus is 95% on terrible
policing and 5% on actual societal
problems I blame the media for not
allowing people on with common sense to
give them a platform and I it's just
like we're responsible I get that and
and I have mixed feelings about Al
Sharpton I've been critical of our
Sharpton in the past and much of that
criticism stands the test of time I
don't back away from any of it but some
I have some modicum of respect for our
Sharpton but I think it's wrong that
we've given him this elevated platform
on television and treat him as the
spokesman for black America I just don't
think he's earned that and I think he
shot his credibility with Tawana Brawley
and other things that a responsible
media would say you know I would like to
find a different voice than our Sharpton
and so I think the same thing with Itano
he see Coates is we've anointed him as
the spokesman for black America and he
keeps singing the same note over and
over and over again
black people anything that happens to
you you're not responsible for there's
these magical way people that are in
control of your lives
and basically what Tana he see coach
went if you understand his point of view
he's basically arguing white people are
God we should worship them and get on
these and beg and pray for them to come
save us I just don't believe in that uh
and I'm most rational people I don't
think believe in
you have to take ownership of your own
destiny and life and if an America has a
track record that if you're willing to
do that you'll find some success here
there's just too many examples of it and
and I'm not talking about and I don't
want to elevate but I'm not talking
about on my level I'm just looking at my
father who didn't graduate from high
school who went to the army who started
a couple little small businesses and
managed to take care of himself and find
happiness here in America with his
friends he filed was married two or
three different times a good-looking guy
he had a good life he enjoyed his life
you can do that here in America and
we're telling people just the opposite
and it's just wrong so talk about the
infusion of politics into sports cuz you
start off the sports columnist like
writing about sports and yet now a lot
of your fame a lot of your notoriety is
based around your political viewpoint
because so much of sports has now been
infused with politics has that changed
over time and maybe I'm too young to
remember it but it seems like when I was
a kid there wasn't quite as much of it
as there is now this kind of complete
merger of politics and I think man if
you you were young and so when you say
like oh I enjoy doing my sports
reporters and I followed your work at
the Kansas City Star
I don't know if you actually remember I
was already delving into these issues
when I was in Kansas City and lacing a
lot of my conversation using sports to
talk about the rest of society and
that's probably what captured your
attention and so to me what has happened
is the left has had a well orchestrated
plan to change sports culture and it's
just all coming to fruition and becoming
obvious now because I think the Left
figured out they'd like sports plays a
very critical role in American society
you go back and understand Robinson in
1947 was a head of the civil rights
movement and actually inspired the civil
rights movement Jesse Owens was the
first black man to be celebrated as a
national hero in America when he goes to
Berlin and winslet
he's the first time America was like hey
a black man jealous national yes yeah
and so those those are critical moments
that open doors for black people and I
think the left coming off of the
Muhammad Ali era started putting pieces
in place well we have if we can
influence sports culture and move it
left we can move the rest of society to
the left and that's what I think we're
seeing right now coming to full fruition
a lot of people a lot of sports writers
and other people have this strong left
wing point of view and want to turn
everything into a racial issue and I'm
watching them right now try to tear down
the NFL because the NFL is the biggest
representation for the left of toxic
masculinity nothing could be more toxic
ly masculine than football and that's
why they're trying to tear it down and
Colin Kaepernick is just a Trojan horse
upon that they're using to bait black
athletes and black sports fans into
having a problem with the NFL they're
painting the NFL as this racist
institution and I'm sitting there going
oh my god there's no institution that
has created more black millionaires than
the NFL and we think it's racist and we
think it's evil and and then just remove
the NFL just football again I'm from a
one-bedroom 400 square foot apartment me
and my dad and football came and took me
out of that and put me on a college ski
they do this for black kids all over the
country where there's division to
division one whatever and we're
attacking football and acting like
football is this racist institution and
before this show as these guys I was
talking to out in the lobby I was like
does Hollywood come to the ghetto and
get Jason Whitlock oh we want you to be
the star of a television show let me get
you at 18 and move you to this theater
school that's not what they do
they pick from the elite
and so as black people I'm just begging
us to understand what are we doing here
are we really analyzing the institutions
that have been beneficial to us and
actually help the poor or are we caught
up in some emotional play and being
tricked and hoodwinked into attacking
the very things that have been
beneficial to us so I'm just second out
and talk about the hijacking of ESPN and
Sports Illustrated so much of other
sports media for this particular point
of view first I need to say thank you to
our sponsors over at Indo Chino so Jason
Whitlock is a good-looking dude who's
wearing a nice nice suit
but even Jason Whitlock would look great
in Indo Chino suit energy Chino is the
world's largest made-to-measure menswear
company and they've been featured in
major publications including GQ Forbes
Fast Company custom-made to order stuff
right they make suits and shirts made to
your exact measurements for a great fit
and guys love the wide selection of high
quality fabrics the option to
personalize all the details including
lapel lining monogram here's how it
works
you go to a showroom or you shop online
in Indo Chino calm and you pick your
fabric you choose your customizations
you submit the measurements and then you
just wait for the custom suit to arrive
in just a few weeks and this week my
listeners can get any premium Indo Chino
suit for just 379 bucks at Indo Chino
comm when you enter been guest at check
out because I have a guest that is 50%
off the regular price from
made-to-measure premium suit the process
by the way is just awesome I went to the
Beverly Hills the store and I checked
out all the fabrics I got to pick out
what the lapels look like it's really
nice you got it with a nice best and it
fit perfectly shipping is free and if it
doesn't fit perfectly then they'll make
it right for you it's Indo Chino kaam
promo code been guest for any premium
suit for just 379 bucks and free
shipping great deal for a suit that will
fit you better than anything off the
rack ever would
okay so Jason let's talk about the
sports media and and exactly how it is
that they've been facilitating the
infiltration of politics into sports so
when I was growing up I subscribed to
Sports Illustrated from basically the
time I was 12 to maybe the time I was 27
so 15 years my life I said and every
morning I'd wake up and I'd run into the
den to watch SportsCenter because this
was the communal space this was the
thing you could talk about with anybody
the water cooler you may not agree on
politics you may not agree on Church may
not agree on life but you can at least
talk about what happened the basketball
game last night and now I flip on ESPN
and from soup to nuts the entire thing
is MSNBC with footballs it is just wild
left-wing perspectives
over and over and over anybody who
anybody who attempts to buck those
left-wing perspectives if you're Chris
Broussard you're immediately outed and
thrown out of thrown out of town if you
if you're you then you are then you're
called an Uncle Tom by a lot of other
folks if you're somebody who works at
ESPN and you even represent a mildly
right-wing perspective this is
considered absolutely outrageous and
out-of-bounds I remember I cancelled my
Sports Illustrated subscription when
they finally put Caitlyn Jenner on the
cover and I thought to myself
listen Caitlyn Jenner is you know a
sentient human being can do whatever
Caitlyn Jenner wants to do with his life
and I believe Caitlyn Jenner's a man
because biologically he's a man but
Caitlyn Jenner was last athletically
relevant when I was not born I was born
1984 Caitlyn Jenner was not athletically
proud when I was born and now I've got
Caitlyn Jenner on the cover of the
sports magazine having nothing to do
with sports but just about Caitlyn
Jenner I feel like I'm being programmed
here I feel like there's an attempt to
take the things I love and then infuse
them with a certain level of messaging
with which I radically disagree number
one do you think that's true at number
two why do you think that sports media
have been so eager to go along with all
of this when it seems like they're boom
eras when they were actually focusing on
sports not when they were focusing as
much on politics I don't know if they
were eagerly doing this they've been
bullied and this is why I say this is an
orchestrated strategic plan to move
sports to the left I wrote in the Wall
Street Journal a couple years ago a year
and a half ago about Deadspin and Gawker
and they're just beating on ESPN for
years they bullied their executives
wrote Expos day's embarrassing their
executives they just in every way
possible Deadspin just attacked ESPN
like a pitbull and the attack was all
about make moving them politically left
and so there became such a pervasive
fear of Deadspin that's been criticizing
some ESPN decision and the John skipper
who was a president at that time and the
executives under him there they had
these rabid ears and their skin was so
thin and they were so tired of the abuse
that they started catering their
decision and their point of view to
please
Deadspin it it sounds crazy that a
little blog could have that much power
but I watched it in real time I worked
at ESPN two separate times the first ear
a guy named George bodenheimer and Mark
Shapiro were in charge and then the
second time John skipper was in charge
and there'd like two different errors
one was I think from you know 2002 maybe
the 2007 and in that era you were
allowed to have be free thinking and
have whatever point of view you want it
and then Deadspin came in and executed
this ten year attack on ESPN and wallah
we have what we have now it's why Curt
Schilling gets fired because they don't
want to deal with the attack from
Deadspin and the attack from social
media and Twitter and so that they've
the entire media though Ben this isn't
just an ESPN thing I've been trying to
explain to people that the cultural and
moral center of America to me used to be
New York you could argue that and
certainly journalistically that was the
center New York it's now San Francisco
because of the social media companies in
the tech industry everything now is
catered how is it gonna land on social
media House Facebook gonna respond House
Twitter gonna respond
how's Google gonna respond and so all of
America is being reprogrammed to San
Francisco values these are silicon
valley based companies with northern
california values that are being imposed
on the rest of america and so the media
used to have a liberal traditional
liberal slant out of New York now it has
a very radicalized extreme liberal slant
coming out of San Francisco in Northern
California and so ESPN has just been
swept up in all of that from the attacks
of Gawker
to everybody being an interested in
clickbait and how things land without
Twitter black
s'matter couldn't exist it couldn't
exist no one would buy that narrative
that cuz again the stats speak for
themselves let's say 700 people get
killed by the police this year I think
statistically four or five hundred of
them are gonna be white people - 300 are
gonna be black people and then you know
I don't know my math is right but those
are black and black people killed by the
police last year was under 20 yes
so it only one Twitter could that false
narrative exist and it's because if you
say something really extreme and
left-wing and say that all the police
force is the the whole thing is just
racist and it just that'll get retweeted
and liked and shared all over social
Twitter and social social media and the
media is addicted to that going viral
became the biggest thing in the world
and the easiest way to go viral is to
say something very radicalized and
left-wing be Bleen and Dunham
on Twitter and you're sure to get 5
million Twitter followers so how do you
think the sports media pull out of this
or do they pull out of this because
right now everybody's cutting the cord
on ESPN and ESPN is just nose-diving I
mean they've had a serious problem with
people not watching their stuff anymore
and it seems like they're doubling down
on the worst strategy humanly possible
which is to add just more
extraordinarily polarizing content with
nobody to even counter the other side
Mike Ditka loses his job over there
because Mike Ditka happens to be
slightly right of center but you've got
everybody over there who's wildly to the
left yeah well they just rehired Keith
over Oh exactly exactly it I think the
market is starting to speak and I think
that their brand has been damaged
because if you understand who sports
fans are they tend to lean a bit more
conservative and so they've irritated
the largest segment of the and so let's
say you're a sports fan but you're not
really political but if you understand
the values taught in sports they're not
political but they are conservative
values taught in sports again I go back
to what I said earlier we fix the
problems from inside this locker room we
don't blame Outsiders you know it's a
pull yourself up by the bootstraps
yeah you're not getting on the field you
can't play
yes and so I think even if you're not
polluting you're kind of like where's
all this victimhood coming from LeBron
James is now on TV and at press
conferences say oh my god and I don't
want to I do want to mock it because it
was silly LeBron James is on TV
he compared someone allegedly riding on
a gate of his 20 million dollar mansion
in Brentwood someone allegedly wrote on
his garage gate the n-word and he
analogized that to Emmett Till and
Emmett Till's mother sharing the pain of
Emmett Till being lynched and
assassinated he analogized that to him
having the n-word written on his 20
million dollar mansion out here in Britt
wood when he's living at the time in
Accra so a home that he's not in
allegedly has the n-word written on it
we never see a picture of it it's it's
he says it was cleaned it was on there
in the morning then his staff cleaned it
up he never saw it his kids weren't
there there was no danger he analogize
it to Emmett Till and and so I'm just
sports fans people with common sense
alike how you're living one of the
greatest wealthiest privilege lives in
the history of America you gotta put him
in the top 1,000 I think that means
worth about a half billion he celebrated
all over the planet anywhere he goes
they rush him in to get seated and gets
preferential treatment and he's on TV
yeah I could have if it could happen to
me if someone could write the N word of
my it could happen it it just doesn't
ring true and I think most sports fans
like this is bat now LeBron James is a
victim so here's one of my theories
about what ESPN is doing so I wrote
about this in terms of demographics so
as you say the sports
and seems to be slightly to the right
because it's a more male audience than
female audience for sports and so if you
were to take a broad demographic of
males versus females males versus
females tend to be more right-wing just
as a general rule but the way that
they're programming on channels like
ESPN is they are basically not covering
baseball at all they cut baseball
tonight they're not programming hockey
virtually at all they program a lot of
the NFL and a lot of the NBA and the
reason for that I think is because when
you look at the studies what the studies
tend to show is that minority audiences
are spending more hours a day watching
ESPN and they also happen to like
basketball more than they like baseball
or more than they like hockey and so
it's as though ESPN has decided to
instead of broadcasting and go for the
broadest possible audience they've
decided to narrow cast and double down
on a certain segment of the audience
that they are going to and that once you
do that it's sort of a vicious circle in
the sense that you have to cater
politically to the audience that you've
already brought to the party so you've
already sent a lot of white folks who
like hockey and baseball we're not
interested in catering to you you don't
watch as much TV
there's another group who watch a lot of
TV so we're gonna cater to that group
and those people tend to be more to the
left and so it's sort of this this
spiral but the problem is that that's
always going to be a smaller and smaller
number of people that you're catering to
as opposed to a broader and broader
I think you're right the only place I
would push back is I think black people
were being programmed and pushed farther
and farther to the left if you
understand anything about the history of
african-americans in this country we are
the most we have been the most religious
people in the country our values are
naturally conservative the things that
we believe it we're not pro-abortion but
we have been pushed by the media farther
left than our values say we should go
we've chosen politics over our belief in
God I talked with my mother about this
all the time she is and again I'm
adamant non-voter
my mother's work for the Democratic
Party loves Barack Obama probably give
me up for adoption to be Barack smother
and I say to her all the time
where's the God but I ask
all the time these policies and things
are where's the God in any of this this
is this is what mama love you are here
mama this is what we stand on show the
Democratic Party's become so secular and
the Left movement has become so sacred
and where they're pushing blacks away
from religion and against all the values
we were brought up with how does this
stand to the test of time MA when you're
going to cuz I pay for to go to these
Bible studies she likes to go to it all
she's a very plain how does any of this
jibe with what you're learning and all
this other stuff and so I I think they
are I think you're right they are
catering to the basketball football
crowd they are catering to a people of
color crowd but I also think they're
pushing a political point of view on
them as well because that's what I look
at the Colin Kaepernick thing I'm like
they have billions of dollars invested
in the NFL and as the company you're
supporting this Kaepernick thing that's
sewing all this bad blood towards the
NFL that's got it that's not good
business that's pushing a political
ideology down the throats of your
viewers and it's just what I want to
talk to you in a second about the the
White House and its controversy with the
Philadelphia Eagles and all of this
first I want to say thanks to our
sponsors over at movement so you've
heard me talk about movement right this
watch right here this is a movement and
watch you know there's two college
dropouts that started their own watch
company well the company has now grown
like crazy with almost 2 million watches
sold in 160 plus countries and they
continue to revolutionize fashion on the
belief that style should not be
extraordinarily expensive I know if
you've checked out their site lately
they've doubled the number of watch
styles and they are still expanding and
movement watches are all about looking
good keeping it simple movement watches
don't tell you how many steps you've
taken they don't blow your wrist up with
text messages it tells the time that's
what it does and it looks great
it looks really spare and awesome
movement watches start at just 95 bucks
at a department store you're looking
like four to five hundred bucks and
movement figured out that by selling
online they can actually cut out the
middleman and save you a bunch of money
providing the best possible price it's
got the classic design and the quality
construction style minimalism as I say
this one right here this year is a
movement watch I have another one at
home my wife has a move
watch my mom has movement watch I got
her for Mother's Day get 15% off today
with free shipping and free returns by
going to MDM t.com slash been guest
that's MDM t-dot-com slash been guest
because i have a guest c ymd mt right
MVM t dock on cy movement keeps growing
check out their expanding collection
again when MDM t.com /a been guest
that's MVM t-dot-com
/ been guest and join the movement okay
so let's talk briefly about the
situation with the White House the
President Trump
I obviously goes at it with the
Philadelphia Eagles my opinion on this
is that President Trump feels like he
can make hay while the Sun shines off of
this controversy this controversy is
good for him politically and the there
are certain members of the Philadelphia
Eagles who feel that they're gonna win
this culture war and so we now have two
sides thinking they're gonna win the
culture war the only people who lose are
the people who like football and people
who like the national anthem and it
seems like them you know - you're -
you're not like in politics point I'm
not sure I've ever disliked politics
quite as much as I do when I see
situations like this because it seems
like if people don't want to up to the
White House that's their prerogative Tim
Thomas didn't want to show up when
Barack Obama was president I don't think
that was a big deal and by the same
token a president Trump implying that
every member who didn't want to show up
didn't like the national anthem seemed
like that was just not true what was
your take on the whole kind of blow up I
think that as black people were way too
caught up in Trump I think that you know
I spoke at my church I grew up in my
mom's church my grandmom's Church
Mother's Day weekend I went home and my
message to the congregation was who are
we worshiping Trump or God and if if you
wake up in the morning and turn on MSNBC
or see it in to monitor what Trump did
last night or this morning and then you
go to bed thinking about or watching TV
monitoring tropica how much time are you
spending monitoring God versus Trump and
it's Trump your God because if all your
conversation or Trump did this or Trump
did that and and I because I'm
questioning my mother my mama I've been
here for days every time you get on the
phone you talk about Trump I go
your focus is on Trump and I'm just like
I think this is an appropriate let's
focus on God and the good things that
are happening
mama you living in a condo that's paid
for a house that I bought you're living
a life that your mother would have
dreamed of living in her golden years
you're living it how can you be focused
on so much negativity
how can your conversation be so negative
when things are going so good and God
has blessed you so well and so I look at
the football players and and I see an
emotional response to Trump Trump is an
entertainer he's a goofball he's our
president I respect him as our president
but I don't have to respond emotionally
to everything he does if he tweets out
something about me that I don't I don't
have to respond to that I and this is my
problem with football players the NFL
has provided them an opportunity to make
great wealth help themselves help them
families you have a short window to make
this money
don't let Trump talk you into doing
things that are hurting your game that
is irritating a good percentage of your
fan base the national anthem bickering
with the president again these guys are
not they're out of their element trying
to carry on a debate with the president
and that's not me trying to belittle
them but they have a short window to
make a lot of money that they can use to
support the causes that they want to
engage it and so I say to them all the
time or try to say schools like make the
money take the money and support the
cause you want don't get caught up in a
bickering with presidential that's what
he does all the time that he loves it
you're playing into his hands don't be
emotional be logical and think about
what works for you in the long run and
so and then let your Malcolm Jenkins the
safety for the Philadelphia Eagles and
you seem to be really involved in this
movement and have more substantive
thoughts if that's the case I never back
away from a chance
to engage with someone I disagree with
and if you have access to the president
regardless of who he is I would have
went to the White House and engaged with
this man and disagree with Trump is for
lack of a better word as it relates to
athletes he's a bit of a groupie he
loves them he would have engaged with
them and debate that's kim kardashian
comes in and gets someone released from
prison he loves it
this is all so he had Malcolm chiggers
these guys have a chance to go engage
with the President and and we're so
caught up in this resistance movement
how much do we understand history do we
think Lyndon Johnson and Martin Luther
King were went to the same church and
lived in the same neighborhood and
socialized in the same circles do we not
know who Lyndon Johnson was and the
language he used and again we could
write it all right at all oh well that's
why how they talked in the 60s but it
was a very racist language what a Martin
Luther King engaged with people he
disagreed with and changed them and so
the message I gave to my mother's church
was and I keep trying to say if if you
think Trump represents hate you think
more hate or hate towards him is gonna
cure it doesn't the Bible teaches does
it hasn't life taught us only love can
conquer hate only the love will work in
turn hate Plus hate multiplies hate love
is the only solution and and so we would
be better off trying to inject President
Trump with love rather than hate and so
that would be my message to the Eagles
or anybody if you really understand
you're gonna catch more flies with honey
if you go it's just it's an improper
approach that seems emotional seems
immature and this is ineffective so
these are all yeah I mean I agree with a
hell of a lot of what you're saying a
lot of people who are on the left
obviously don't know why black folks
don't agree with what you're saying how
do you deal with the with the blowback
that you've gotten over the years
because you've gotten a tremendous
amount of blowback about a
hit pieces on you have been written he's
ten thousand were hit pieces about why
you're an Uncle Tom and why you you
don't believe the right way and why
you're a sellout and all this how do you
deal with that on a personal I just I go
back to mama loving and the church I
grew up in and if God's on your side I
really don't care and so I have a great
family that loves me and supports me I
have great friends who love and support
me that these random people that don't
know me I really don't care and and I'm
not I'm not doing anything all that
courageous but I really do believe the
things that I was taught in church and
so I'm like a if they would kill and
crucify Jesus
ten thousand word hippies on me it
really just rolls off my back so do you
think things are gonna get better or
worse from here because I think there is
a new conversation that's starting from
people of all political stripes are
getting very tired of the sort of
identity politics that are happening
right now the attempts to label each
other if we disagree then you're an
Uncle Tom or I'm a racist and it doesn't
matter what we actually are how we
personally interact this intersectional
politics where identity matters more
than perspective are you hopeful for the
future do you think things are gonna
continue to deteriorate the way things
are going right now I'm hopeful because
I think we've dealt with worse in this
country and and I just rely on my faith
for one but also I see signs I think
when Kanye West for whatever we may
think about him when he goes out on that
limb and says anyway let's think a
little more independently let's not
demonize the president totally let's not
demonize people totally let's let's
think let's try to get beyond our
surface level emotions and feelings and
I mean he's a tastemaker for lack of a
better word and and so and then what III
think that one of the blue my black
friends and the people I interact with
on a daily basis
I think there there's more and more
understanding of where I'm coming from
and but just also I see more and more
understanding of the failure of being
wedded to one political ideology and I
think that the understand I was telling
people for years ago hey look black
lives matters not what you think
you think it's a Pro black movement it's
not it's it's funded by communists in
its a disrupter and I've tried to
explain to people it's just like black
labs no matter to me which Trump's
running mate that that more than almost
anything that I can point to black lives
matters helped Trump get elected and I
try to explain and people are now
starting to get that and understand it
and so yeah I am hopeful that there's an
awakening because III think look if the
unemployment rate keeps coming down and
and just the facts I'll say this when
when President Obama got elected I had a
conservative white female friend who
used to make all these dramatic
predictions about what was going to
happen when President and I would just
be calling BS on all of it
oh my god well terrorists are gonna tell
you I was like are you kidding me oh and
none of it came true and a lot of her
most biggest fears never came true under
president and I think the same things
gonna happen with President Trump that a
lot of these biggish outlandish fears
that people have just aren't going to
come true
and that's not me saying that President
Trump is going to be a great president I
don't think you know I don't think it's
healthy to have a reality TV star as the
president and someone who tweets like
that I don't think that's a good thing
but I don't think the the worst fears
are gonna come true and people are just
gonna have to deal with the reality
because at least I've tried to and I I
don't want to come off I don't want to I
don't care how it lands I said to my
mother back
early on with the Trump thing and and
just keeping it a thousand percent real
whether I was like mama how is Trump in
some of his abrasive outlandish
statements and particularly his sexual
in pariah t how's that any different
than your brother Uncle John who we love
I worship how's he any different that's
tough for Jonna Uncle John and president
Trump would have been drinking buddies
and I'm chasing it together right so I
just can't go there I just can't I can't
I know people that think the same way is
Trump but they're black they're
outlandish they're over the top a lot of
things they say are stupid but they're
good people and my dad and you know God
rest his soul
my dad was prejudiced he did not like
white people but you know what trumped
his bigotry he wanted to be a good
person so anybody that came into his bar
any person he encountered he'd met them
with respect and I saw a guy that would
you know upset cuz awful things happen
to my dad along racial lines a kid that
made him very bitter but I never saw him
mistreat anyone ever because that was
more important than whatever bigotry he
held within him and that's I try to
explain to people that I know a lot of
people with inappropriate thoughts and
ideas but not all of those interpret
they don't control all their behavior
there's other things they have that may
trump their bigotry whatever being a
good person being religious wanting to
be right with God can trump a lot of the
stupid thoughts we have and that's why
when I hear people try to disavow
religion or beat up religion or whatever
and looked at the church clearly isn't
perfect and it's made a lot of mistakes
but I've just seen too much and know too
much and know when my parents divorced
and my mother's single mother in the 70s
raising two
lack boys I know what God and the church
did for her to get her through and so I
so yeah I'm hopeful well Jason Whitlock
thank you so much for stopping by really
is a pleasure to have you here and I'm
so glad that we could bring you to our
audience which may not have heard a lot
of your stuff you check Jason Whitlock
out over at Fox Sports 1 he's just
awesome thanks so much for stopping by
really appreciate you boo
[Music]
Avenger Pierrot shows Sunday special is
produced by Jonathan hey executive
producer Jeremy borin associate
producers Mathis Glover and Austin
Stevens edited by Alex Singaram audio is
mixed by Mike Karenina hair and makeup
is by Jess wah all vera and title
graphics by Cynthia and gula Ben Shapiro
shows Sunday special is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright
board Publishing 2018
[Music]